bonjour à tous merci à tous présents cet
après midi pour assister au marathon de
conférences du café des sciences
nous verrons dans plusieurs disciplines
comment la science et la fiction sur
offrons tous peuvent parfois se
rejoindre
pas moins de sept conférences des
marathoniens deux dessinatrices helena
et bellichi qui ont dessiné en live dans
les dessins sont sur twitter et sur le
stand du café des sciences par la suite
et nous allons vraiment c'est sans plus
attendre avec à ses pieds aux et premium
premium premium du mieux ça marche très
bien sur alexandre le grand contre les
démons dans ses rêves simples
intoxication à les revenus
[Applaudissements]
au départ mes bien chers frères mes
vidéos sur soeur aujourd'hui on va
discuter un peu de people parce que
j'avais pas fiction sous les yeux et
s'allume bien ça nous permet d'être bien
un personnage que j'affectionne
énormément qui s'appelle saint-antoine
de legrand donc on va parler un peu de
son histoire à cette empreinte de main
d'oeuvre elle aussi dans l'âme un mec
qui a un de la classe dans cette zone le
grand il est connu c'est un régime siens
sur une riche famille d'agriculteurs un
qui est née entre eux au début 251 qui
est mort en 356 après jésus-christ donc
le christianisme à l'époque c'était un
peu la région qui démarrait c'était pas
terrible et ça commençait à venir et le
mec est spécialement connue parce que à
un moment donné il était très riche tout
ça et s'inquiétait beaucoup de son salut
et lee un verset de la bible qui dit
navré saint-mathieu abandonne tout et
part sur les routes donc mais qui lit
une phrase qui veulent et du coup ils
abandonnent tous vivent tous qu'il a
toutes ses possessions et il part sur
l'hérault qui va occuper un château qui
était complètement abandonné dans le
désert de nubie je crois et ce mec part
sur les routes il avant même tout divine
vie d'ascète de ce qu'on appelle
précisément ta l'accord est donc
anachorète c'est pas un insecte qui nous
tendons bien karner par le secret c'est
une vie complètement derniers temps où
on n'a pas de possession physique où on
n'a pas de rapport sexuel
voilà c'est une vie complètement dévoué
à dieu et à penser adieu donc le mec il
vit sa vie comme ça il n'y a pas grand
chose ils n'ont pas de vêtements il se
fait livrer un sac de farine de seigle
de temps en temps pour faire du plein
pour manger quelque chose parce que
sinon
et il s'habille comme ça la légende de
saint-antoine veut que l'idée rencontrés
dans le désert il a eu des apparitions
d'apparition qui sont ses habits de
moine ses 28 ans après il ya des
apparitions qui sont complètement
fantasmé qui sont à la fois des
apparitions démoniaque ou des
apparitions tentatrices et ce qu'on
appelle les tentations de saint-antoine
vous avez différentes oeuvres qui les
décrivent tu peux passer on va passer à
delhi je pense voilà avec des femmes des
femmes à poil vous avez des animaux
effrayant tout ça tout ça c'est la
tentation de saint antoine
il a des apparitions qui sont divines
qui sont là pour le tenter pour
l'éloigner du chemin et lui il va
continuer à adorer dieu et à se battre
contre ces tentations donc c'est
vraiment quelque chose dans l'imaginaire
entre guillemets qui est considéré le
mec se bat en permanence pour résister à
la tentation 1 et il a des
hallucinations et il se bat lorsqu'il a
c'est lorsqu'il à ses visions il se bat
contre des démons et d'ailleurs il a des
stigmates c'est à dire qu'il va voir à
des blessures au niveau des mains au
niveau des jambes dont qui se bat
vraiment contre quelque chose il ya
quelque chose qui se passe à ce moment
là donc vraiment la vie de saint-antoine
c'est une vie de se battre contre des
démons et le fait le fait qu'ils aient
tous ces stigmates et toutes ces choses
comme ça ça va faire qui va être suivi
adoré et c'est même le père reconnu de
tous les ordres monastiques c'est à dire
que tous les moines qui sont dans des
monastères tous à leurs pères leurs
seins percés saint-antoine
donc ça c'est son histoire mais la
question qu'on s'est posée avec françois
c'est entre guillemets est-ce qu'on n'a
pas une autre explication que des
visions à démoniaque pour expliquer ce
qui est arrivé à ce bon vieux
saint-antoine parce que c'est bien la
bible ou les récits bibliques qui sont
autour mais est ce qu on a pas d
explication un peu plus scientifique
alors moi j'aimerais vous parliez d'un
champignon
pas forcément en rapport mais je vais
vous parler d'un champignon le
champignon question c'est alors on peut
à l'excès de palets gore l'écorché ce
qu'on a ce moment quelque part clavis
eps purpura ou a aussi appelé ergo de
seigle l'ergot de seigle
c'est ce qu'on voit là c'est un champion
qui fait des petits ergots sur le
segment sais pas si vous vous souvenez
mais certains thèmes il se faisait
livrer des farines de la farine de
seigle pour faire son pain alors l'ergot
de seigle mons est connu pour maintenant
pour faire deux choses on vienne monique
et l'acompte merde donc leurs gosses
aigles maintenance est connu pour plein
de choses mais c est ça produit des
alcaloïdes un malentendu produits
chimiques qui y font deux choses
particulières l'une de ses premières
choses alors c'est ça un effet
vasoconstricteur c'est leur quota mines
l'orgue au tamis non l'utilisent à
l'heure actuelle c'est un médicament
contre les dérivés de l'ergot de seigle
font des médicaments qui font un effet
de constriction des vaisseaux les
vaisseaux les plus petits vaisseaux vont
se fermer ce qui l'a entraîné en défaut
d'afflux de 100 dans certaines parties
alors généralement plus haut taux son
petit plus ça va être marqué c'est pour
ça que ça touche principalement les
extrémités les bras les jambes la peau
chose comme ça et donc ça fait ce qu'on
appelle des gangrènes alors pas la
gangrène infectieuses qui
dégueulasse ça cool ça pue voilà tout ça
c'est plutôt des grandes gueules sèches
vraiment nécro certes le sens n'arrive
plus ça sèche ça meurt et ça ça pourrait
nous expliquer nos stigmates de notre
bon saint-antoine qui lui manger quand
même beaucoup de choses à base de seigle
il ya quelque chose aussi à comprendre
c'est que à l'époque les gens quand on
est des nécroses on a le doigt qui
devient tout noir qui tombe donc en fait
les anciens décrivez cette peste ardente
pas ce que ça donnait des douleurs de
brûlures qui était vraiment intense et
on avait l'impression que les doigts et
les pieds entre guillemets se carboniser
de l'intérieur donc les gens avaient
l'impression qu'ils brûlaient de
l'intérieur et c'est vraiment ce qui
donne cette dénomination de mal des
ardents de paix stars d'antan et du feu
de saint-antoine le fameux feu de
saint-antoine la deuxième chose c'est
que effectivement ses responsables alors
ça c'est les petites traces qu'on peut
voir des ddd né des plages de nécrose
des douleurs abdominales des déserts des
douleurs atroces des zones qui voit là
des morceaux qui tombe voit la joie
bonheur félicité la deuxième chose c'est
que ça produit aussi de l'acide
lysergique l'acide lysergique c'est
c'est un hallucinant du carnage du silo
gêne et comme le monsieur l'a fait si
bien remarquer c'est l'un de ses dérivés
il s'appelle diéthylamide d'acide les
sergic est aussi connue sous le nom de
lsd donc on a un élément qui se trouve
dans le seigle plus ou moins moisi qui
peut se manger qui est correspond à des
douleurs des brûlures qui peut créer des
trous des pertes de
de peau ou même de deux parties de
l'organisme puisque on peut perdre des
doigts ou des les orteils de choses
comme ça et qui peut faire délirer
la question qu'on pourrait se poser est
ce que notre bon saint-antoine
il se serait pas juste fait masse de
trip sous lsd quoi donc c'est ça donc le
briquet rien avoir apparemment c'est
totalement tort la vraie la vraie
question entre guillemets derrière tout
ça c'est que effectivement le mal le mal
de la le phare dans le mal à
le mâle de saint-antoine comme il est
décrit c'est très probablement ce qu'on
peut assimiler à de l'air gothisme c'est
à dire une intoxication qui est dû à
l'ergot de seigle notamment parce qu'il
mangeait que de la farine de seigle qui
étaient avariés parce qu'il la prenait à
pas cher parce qu'il y avait une vie de
pauvreté est donc entre guillemets c'est
assez vision peuvent s'apparenter à un
délire hallucinatoire kiprop due à un
précurseur du lsd effectivement il faut
savoir aussi et c'est là dessus que je
terminerais que l'ergot tisme c'est une
maladie qui atteint beaucoup de villages
comme ça et notamment il ya une histoire
assez célèbre qui est celle des
sorcières de salem et sorcières de salem
elle faisait des crises d'air gothisme
de la même manière qui leur donnait les
hallucinations et des troubles
psychiatriques qui pouvaient entre
guillemets expliqué qui a réalisé ces
crises de folie et tout ça avec tout ça
donc ça crée beaucoup de peur et on
assimiler ça une peste parce que la
peste c'était un peu tous les mots qu'on
pouvait avoir comme ça et voilà ça y est
nous allons passer à la suite
et je vais vous présenter quelqu'un de
merveilleux 1
c'est l'animatrice de passer sauvage
clotilde qui va nous parler
d'archéologie et plus précisément
indiana jones
merci à vous
[Applaudissements]
la droite ok on va commencer par une
question stupide et puis le niveau
montera après vous avez tous vu indiana
jones
ok allez on va commencer par la question
qui fâche indiana jones est il un
archéologue
non ok bon ben on va développer un peu
patience et pas très drôle dans
l'indiana jones n'a rien à l'archéologue
c'est au mieux un chasseur de trésors à
la mode
19e siècle et ce qui pose en fait ce qui
pose problème moi je vais vous expliquer
ce qui marche pas en tant qu'arc et au
look puisque c'est mon métier
et puis on verra qui est des choses qui
fonctionnent quand même alors le premier
truc qui choque dans ses films c'est la
vision de l'autre de l'étranger qui est
intégrée au monde sauvage va dire qui
confrontés au monde et civilisé
ce monde sauvage il n'a jamais
d'espace-temps c'est à dire que vous ne
savez jamais vraiment où vous êtes vous
êtes vaguement dans la jungle
à un moment il est ou de pointer au
milieu voilà et des mecs qui courent qui
représente le danger
vous ne savez jamais de quand datent les
objets qu'on vous montre
et d'ailleurs les décors et les objets
qu'on vous présente ne sont absolument
pas réaliste c'est qu'ils ne peuvent
même pas exister là ça c'est un mélange
de maillard égyptiens on sait pas trop
vous pouvez faire tous les musées du
monde vous trouvera jamais ce truc et là
on est censé être dans un temple
égyptien
sauf que le toit est voûté
or la voûte soit invite à inventer des
millénaires plus tard donc ça ne
fonctionne pas bon après tout ces
incohérences c'est pas très grave
puisqu'on est dans une fiction je sais
plus
voilà où seulement une fiction c'est
très bien nous sommes toujours et donc
moi ma question c'est est ce que ba et
nina jones a un rapport avec
l'archéologie
donc là je vais vous parler uniquement
du premier indiana jones les aventuriers
de l'arche perdue et donc petit rappel
de l'histoire on né en 1936 indiana et
en amérique du sud au début et puis il
est appelé par ces deux mecs là qui sont
des représentants des services secrets
américains qui vont l'envoyer au caire
parce qu'au caire il ya des fouilles
organisées par les nazis les nazis
cherche ce truc là qui est l'arche
d'alliance qui contient les tables de la
loi
bref sans s'en fiche ce qu'il faut
retenir c'est que les nazis cherche des
objets religieux des reliques
alors oui il ya un truc très très
intéressant dans ce film qu'est ce qu'il
va faire voilà non pardon il ya un truc
très intéressant dans ce film qui
fonctionne au niveau historique c'est
justement ce que je vous ai dit les
nazis c'est un fait hyper important pour
20e siècle les fouilles dirigées par les
nazis qui est expliqué par cet extrait
qui est pour moi l'extrait le plus
important dit nyan à jones que je vous
passe puisque ben la fin de la
conférence
on va parler uniquement de ce passage la
hanche et pas si on peut lancer la vidéo
s'il vous plaît
[Musique]
ok sa dernière phrase elle est très très
importante vous enregistrer donc ce que
dit ce mec là à brobo dit claire est
tout à fait juste hitler est un
fanatique été complètement obsédé par
les objets antiques et les aigles et
croix gammée ce sont des symboles hérité
de l'antiquité et donc à partir de 1930
ça marche plus le pointeur
je conduis à partir de 1930 hitler va
envoyer va envoyer des équipes de
fouilles d'archéologues nazis un petit
peu partout dans l'europe etc
ses missions consistent à ramener des
objets des reliques des objets religieux
en allemagne pourquoi ils cherchent pas
en allemagne parce que en allemagne au
niveau aa requis au c'est pas la folie
il ya que des vestiges préhistoriques ou
protohistorique nous ces âges du bronze
âge du fer
il aurait bien voulu aller en italie
mais il ya déjà mussolini qu qui a
commencé cette récupération
donc il va faire ça un petit peu partout
en europe et ça c'est un fait qui est
très intéressant pour pour l'histoire
unique et surtout peu évoquée dans le
cinéma surtout par la seconde guerre
mondiale n'a pas le temps on s'intéresse
au combat à la shoah
et pour ça ce film est juste et présente
un intérêt alors au départ j'avais
décidé d'arrêter là pour la conférence
est en fait en en prenant l'extrait que
vous venez de voir ben je me suis rendu
compte qu'on pouvait lire indiana jones
d'une façon complètement différente
à partir de cette phrase justement vous
séchez le catéchisme alors là ce que je
vais vous dire c'est que ma vision et on
peut en discuter plus tard mais pour moi
indiana jones ce n'est pas un film sur
l'archéologie c'est même pas un film sur
un archéologue qui cherchent des objets
précieux c'est un film sur la bible et
c'est même un cours de catéchisme
alors pourquoi on m'a déjà ya cette
phrase qui n'est là jones eddy qui est
lourde de sens et l ai pas dit devant
n'importe qui l ai dit devant ses deux
gus là qui sont des représentants de
l'état par un prof de fac
donc la hiérarchie elle est complètement
inversé ici et ça se voit même dans le
traitement de la caméra en en
contre-plongée et puis il faut regarder
où est-ce qu'on commet et la pièce on
est pas on est censé être dans une haie
dans une université
on n'est pas dans une salle de classe
classique on n'est pas non plus dans un
amphithéâtre on est dans une salle tout
en longueur il ya des grandes vitres ar
on dit qu'on les vitraux et puis à des
rangées de chaises
en fait on se croirait dans une église
l'autre qui n'a appuyé ce que donne 2
en cette idée parmi c'est ce tableau ce
tableau là qui pendant toute la séquence
voyant plans larges d'accord et vous
voyez les écritures il ya un premier
indice qui est l'ombre d' indiana jones
qui vient balayer à chaque fois les
écritures et cette ombre elle n'est pas
naturelle c'est pas mon nombre là que
vous voyez ces nombres qui accentuait ya
un projet qui vient d'ici
pourquoi la voix mieux et ben en fait ça
c'est une annonce de ce qui va suivre et
je vous montre ce qui va suivre à leiria
pas le sont parce que je vais parler en
même temps alors ces écritures tu peux
l'annoncer chemin tu ne parles ces
écritures c'est quoi ces des calculs
s'était chiffré à des fractions il ya
des racines carrées c'est l'écriture
scientifique
d'accord la culture scientifique c'est
par essence d'écriture de la preuve de
la vérité au moins de la recherche
alors regardez ce qu'ils vont en faire
indiana jones de l'écriture scientifique
il va la retourner la masquer et faire
proposer son interprétation des faits là
il dessine un objet religieux une
relique et à partir de là bas le film ne
parle plus l'archéologie
il parle d'un autre texte sont pas des
écritures scientifique c'est la bible là
qu'ils ouvrent et le texte vous allez
voir on va prendre toute l'image et ça
fait un peu comme les les génériques de
début disney savez quand on ouvre un
grimoire et l'histoire commence à partir
de ce moment là voilà c'est exactement
ça il ya eu 20 minutes de film ou
indiana jones cours dans la jungle on
s'en fout on va plus parler de ça
maintenant on va parler de la bible
voilà c'est tout merci
[Applaudissements]
ainsi dans le city market inscrit cette
fois vers les mathématiques présenté par
lg kick
alors du coup vous de moi j'ai deux
nations dans la ville est l'une des
relations les mathématiques deuxième
passion regarder des films mais plus
précisément regarder des films de
mathématiques et même c'est encore un
petit peu plus précis que ça c'est à
dire que j'aime regarder des films de
mathématiques et m'arrêter sur les
scènes où il ya des équations pour
vérifier si les équations sont corrects
ou pas alors bon c'est vrai ça peut
paraître assez particulier comme hobby
mais en fait des films de mathématiques
qui en a finalement pas mal on vient de
voir
indiana jones avec une scène avec des
équations et du coup je me suis posé la
question combien ce qui n'existe de tels
films de films qui parlent de maths
alors du coup un premier réflexe quand
on a ce genre de questions on va sur
wikipédia et wikipédia à une liste assez
incroyable de films qui parlent de
mathématiques et qui en donne une liste
de précisément 42
vous pouvez compter sauf que du coup
dans cette liste il ya quand même des
choses qui m'embête un petit peu
notamment
il met jurassic park dans la liste des
films qui parlent de maths alors pour
moi non je récite part que ne parle pas
de la thématique du coup je me suis créé
main classification des films de
matières une classification de 0 à 5
pour préciser la place qu'occupent les
mathématiques dans les films alors on
commence avec les films de niveau zéro
c'est les films qui parlera pas du tout
de mattia des maths
nulle part dans le film dont globalement
ces films qui pour moi ne sont pas
intéressants donc la moustache
l'histoire d'un mec qui se rase la
moustache aucun rapport avec les maths
fast and furious 4 bon il ya quelques il
ya quelques vitesse des choses comme ça
mais bon parent par les matches était
une fois en amérique absolument
inintéressant
ensuite on parle aux films n'ont pas ce
film de niveau 1 alors ça est fini de
niveau 1 cd films qui quand on voit le
titre on dit ah là ça va être
intéressant mais en fait après c'est
très décevant
donc pentagone des peurs qui parle pas
du tout de figures géométriques l'eau 17
pays qui parle pas du tout de nombres ou
calculs meurtriers avec aucune scène
d'équations enfin très très décevant
comme film on passe en fit ensuite à des
films de niveau 2 c'est-à-dire des films
dans lequel à un moment il ya des maths
mais fond c'est pas vraiment le sujet
alors par exemple la solitude des
nombres premiers qui est un film qui
quand on voit le titre on va se dire par
là c'est intéressant ça a parlé de nos
premiers en fait est juste une scène à
un moment donné où il évoque les noms
premier pour donner le titre au film et
c'est à peu près tout très très décevant
et donc c'est l'histoire d'une d'une
jeune fille anorexique qui tombe
amoureux d'un garçon qui a pas mal de
problème aussi c'est très déprimant
comme film ça aucun rapport avec les
maths jeu d'enfant infime mais qu'a donc
guillaume canet marion cotillard dans ce
film marion cotillard interprète une
étudiante en date il ya une scène assez
gênante dans lequel on à guillaume canet
qui essayent de draguer en utilisant des
métaphores mathématiques
je voulais mettre l'extrait au début
mais je me suis dit en fait non c'est
vraiment très très gênant donc j'ai
préféré pas le mettre et on a d'un
exemple cinéman par par yann moix qui
avant de faire de la télé réaliser des
films
il a bien fait d'arrêter quand on voit
le film
donc c'est l'histoire d'un professeur de
mathématiques qui devient un cinéma bref
film de niveau 2 cd films qui se peuvent
être intéressants mais en fait non
maintenant on passe maintenant au vrai
film de matt donc c'est à partir des
films de niveau iii que je considère que
c'est des films de maths par exemple le
monde de nathan l'histoire d'un jeune
autiste qui qui découvre un petit peu la
vie grâce aux mathématiques on à agora
le biopic de la mathématicienne de
l'antiquité hypatie où le film cube avec
des personnages enfermés dans un
labyrinthe cubique et le cube répond à
des règles des règles mathématiques
donc tout ça c'est des films qui parlent
de maths mais pas que il ya aussi pas
mal d'autres choses intéressantes à voir
dans le film et du coup si on s'arrête
juste aux maths on passe quand même à
côté de pas mal de choses on passe aux
films de niveau 4 alors là encore plus
de maths c'est à dire des films où tout
tourne autour des mathématiques c'est à
dire que on suit la vie de
mathématiciens avec des problématiques
liées au mcs liés aux démonstrations ce
genre de choses par exemple l'homme qui
défie l infini biopic du mathématicien
ramano de jeanne marie l'histoire d'une
jeune d'une gamine prodige en
mathématiques avec son père joué par
chris evans qui essayent d'obtenir sa
garde ou prof avec gwyneth paltrow
anthony hopkins l'histoire d' une
mathématicienne qui essaye de comprendre
son père à travers les démonstrations
d'un théorème donc c'est des films avec
des problématiques vraiment très liées
aux mathématiques qui du coup pour moi
sont plutôt intéressants et qui en fait
pour le grand public aussi donne le
genre de questions qu'on peut retrouver
et qui sont vraiment propre aux
mathématiques mais c'est quand même des
films grand public que je vous conseille
et enfin les filles de niveau 5
c'est les fines avec des maths partout
tout le temps
donc c'est à dire des films dans lequel
les personnages sont des concepts
mathématiques le monde est un concept
mathématiques l'histoire tourne autour
des mathématiques alors j'ai trouvé
qu'un seul exemple flatland c'est à dire
l'histoire d'un quart et qui découvrent
la troisième dimension
ce film existe vraiment un jeu alors du
coup je me suis fait ma propre liste de
films j'en ai compté une vingtaine et je
me suis dit il faut que je regarde tous
alors j'ai pris deux semaines j'ai
essayé de regarder tous les fils bon
j'ai pas réussir je n'ai regardé qu'une
douzaine mais douze films qui parlent de
maths à suivre faut quand même les tenir
et du coup de dents j'ai découvert des
choses assez incroyables du pire comme
du meilleur
alors exemple du pire film que j'ai pu
voir c'est un film qui s'appelle raising
genious alors le pitch du film est
plutôt simple c'est l'histoire d'un
génie en maths qui s'enferment dans la
salle de bains familiale
du coup forcément à sa famille veut l'en
déloger et pourquoi est ce qui fait ça
pour pouvoir être tranquille pour
pouvoir gribouillé des formules
mathématiques sur les murs sur la douche
et aussi pour avoir une vue privilégiée
sur le jardin de sa voisine qui est
pomme qui est une pom pom girls et qui
fait du trampoline
le film est aussi intéressant que laisse
supposer son pitch donc c'est un bon
gros nanar et il ya juste à voir l'intro
du film on se dit qu'on va passer un
très bon moment 1
et du coup j'ai aussi découvrir des
films un peu plus intéressant donc par
exemple les figures de l'ombre qui est
sorti l'année dernière qui raconte
l'histoire de trois mathématicienne de
la nasa qui sont donc des femmes et qui
sont noirs à une époque où c'était très
mal vu d'être à un poste de
responsabilité en été en femme ou en
étant noir
donc du coup 3 pionners 3 pionnière dans
leur domaine film à voir du cou qui
permet d'avoir de connaître un petit peu
la petite histoire de la conquête de
l'espace et du coup en regardant tous
ces films j'en suis arrivée en fait à
l'idée qu'il ya finalement seulement
trois types de scénarios qui existe dans
les films de maths premier type de
scénario c'est un personnage qui est un
génie et on raconte son histoire donc
par exemple will hunting et l'histoire
d'un l'histoire d'un balayeur qui est
gêné en maths marie l'histoire d'une
gamine qui est ingénieur matt l'homme
qui défie l'infini et l'histoire d'un
indien qui est ingénieur en maths etc
mais il n'ya pas que ça qu'on retrouve
dans les films de mathématiques on
retrouve aussi des histoires avec des
personnages qui ont des troubles mentaux
qui sont fous qui sont autistes dans
l'exemple proof l'histoire d'un
mathématicien qui devient fou le nombre
23 avec jim carrey qui devient fou le
nombre le monde de nathan l'histoire
d'un autiste et évidemment on a des
choses à l'intersection des deux avec pi
l'histoire d'un génie qui vient
fourasine genus l'histoire d'un génie
qui est fou etc et enfin dernier type de
film qui parle de maths c'est quand on a
un mathématicien qui va sauver le monde
ou sauver les siens
et pareil donc la chambre de fermat
l'histoire de mathématiciens enfermés
dans un piège qui doivent s'en sortir
grâce aux maths et c'est donc là c'était
juste une introduction pour en savoir un
petit peu plus je vous renvoie à ma
chaîne youtube dans lequel j'ai
décortique plus précisément quelques
films qui parlent de mathématiques comme
par exemple le film cube ou le film
l'homme qui défiait l'infini je vous
remercie de m'avoir écouté
[Applaudissements]
la bonne toi merci donc maintenant
affaire rappelle un peu à votre enfance
du côté du livre de la jungle et de
mowgli qui désolé de vous l'apprendre
simuler totalement les chatteries qu'il
subissait peintres des eaux
présenté par valentine et morgane de
science de comptoir merci quel public
génial donc bonjour à tous on va
commencer par vous montrer un extrait
d'un chef-d'oeuvre du septième art donc
un documentaire animalier engagé et
immersif
c'est luc jacquet à son apogée alors je
me plains peut alors ça va vous ça se
passe bien voilà merci
[Musique]
non non et non dans une chose qui fait
pas dans l'album arrête les chatouilles
supporte pas encore jet tours au secours
berrabah ça tu l'as cherché tu n'as que
ce que tu mérites
alors qu'au niveau du capitaliste ouais
tu me plais ça c'est fait alors comme
vous avez pu voir dans l'extrait balou
s'est fait défoncer sa mère dans mon
glee s'est fait chatouiller jusqu'à
mourir de rire
et j'aimerais savoir vous à votre avis
qu'est ce qui se serait passé s'il n'y
avait pas eu
mowgli en gros si bâle où était tout
seul dans la jungle et qu'il avait
essayé de se chatouiller lui même se
serait pas passé grand chose j'ai
entendu ok donc d'après vous il se
serait rien passé
vous avez vous avez l'air bien sûr de
vous est ce que vous avez déjà testé
chez vous de vous chatouiller vous même
ouais ça marche pas donc d'après notre
expérience à tous
on peut dire que les chatouilles on peut
pas se chatouiller soi même donc nous
dans cette conférence sont bikes essayer
de comprendre ensemble pourquoi est-ce
qu'on peut pas se chatouiller tout seul
en rêve
on va voir pourquoi est-ce que ça
intéresse les scientifiques et surtout
on va vous donner les moyens de quand
même réussir à vous chatouiller mais
voilà en deux mots on va changer votre
vie donc pour commencer on va commencer
par vous expliquer pourquoi
enfin on va voir ensemble pourquoi on ne
peut pas se chatouiller soi même et pour
ça on va faire une petite expérience
collective donc vous inquiétez pas tout
va bien se passer c'est totalement
indolore aucun animal ne sera maltraité
pendant l'expérience
donc on va vous demander soyez pas
timide c'est pour la science de prendre
votre main droite de dit je le jure non
c'est pas ça et posez la sur votre
épaule
voilà on attend encore un peu c'est
gênant c'est que le début maintenant
prenez prenez cette même manche il faut
la retirer et posez la sur l'épaule de
votre voisin de droite c'est pour la
science
et concentrez vous voilà maintenant
concentrez-vous sur les sensations de la
main étrangère sur votre épaule
c'est bon vous pouvez arrêter
c'est la fin de l'expérience même si
beaucoup de vous être vous être prêté
donc maintenant c'est beau pouvait
respirer un bon coup faire quelques
génuflexion voilà c'est fini
merci donc maintenant on va essayer de
tirer des conclusions
face à cette merveilleuse expérience que
vous venez de faire donc est ce que vous
avez senti des choses différentes
selon la main qui était posé sur votre
épaule c'était la vôtre voilà une
température qui étaient différentes
c'était comment pas c'était comment
d'accord nous plus froides
peut-être la pression qui était
différente aussi donc en gros ce qu'on
peut dire c'est que on est moins on est
plus sensible quand c'est une main
étrangère qui se pose sur notre épaule
plus tôt quand c'est là notre propre
donc en d'autres termes on est moins
sensible quand on se touche soi même que
quand quelqu'un d'autre nous touchent et
mais pourquoi donc du coup pourquoi
et c'est ça en fait qui se passe quand
on se chatouillent soi même ce qu'on est
moins sensible à nos propres mouvements
ok donc ce qu'il faut c'est comprendre
pourquoi du coup on est moins sensible à
nos propres mouvements par rapport à
ceux des autres donc pour ça on va
revoir l'action au ralenti vas-y donc
valentine s'apprête à poser sa main
droite sur son épaule pendant que la
main se rapproche en fait son cerveau
est en plein en pleine ébullition on
dirait pas comme ça mais il en train de
calculer la distance à laquelle elle
enfin la distance pour que la main
arrive bien sur l'épaule et pas dans sa
tête pour qu'elle arrive avec une
pression suffisante mais pas qu'elle
foute un point dans l'épaule pour
qu'elle arrive enfin il en train de
prédire aussi les sensations qu'elle va
ressentir sur son épaule c'est à dire
est ce que la main va être chaude froide
est-ce que ça va être doué ce que ça va
piquer ou est ce que ça va faire mal
donc il fait une prédiction est ensuite
bam la main arrive sur l'épaule hélas le
cerveau confronte la prédiction qui l'a
fait avec la réalité
ou quand la main arrive on a tous nos
capteurs sensoriels là qui s'activent et
qui envoie une alerte au cerveau pour
lui dire ce qui se passe
les messages nerveux arrive et lui
disent ah bah effectivement la main et
tiède c'est plutôt une sensation douce
agréable et ses légères et donc y
compare la prédiction avec la réalité
est là c'est le truc super important
attention concentration c'est que avec
nos propres mouvements
la prédiction correspond quasiment
toujours à la réalité parce qu'on se
connaît on connaît notre corps on sait
on est par exemple capable de toucher et
son poignet sans même le voir ce qu'on
sait où sont situés nos différentes
parties du corps etc
et donc ce qui se passe c'est ce qu'on
appelle le concept d'atténuation
sensorielle claquons la prédiction est
comparée à la réalité et les sensations
sont atténuées parce qu'en fait ça
correspond parfaitement aux attentes du
cerveau donc on ressent presque rien
quand on se touche soi même ok et
s'apparente c'est pareil quand on se
chatouillent soi même donc voilà spike
canton se chatouille par contre ce qui
se passe quand on touche quelqu'un enfin
ans quand on se fait toucher par
quelqu'un est plutôt c'est qu'il n'y a
pas de prédiction parce qu'on n'est pas
capable de savoir quelle est la texture
de la main de l'autre tila les manches
froide ou chaude si fait un mouvement
violent ou pas donc on est surpris en
fait le cerveau est surpris y'a pas
d'atténuation sensorielle et on se met à
rigoler s'il ya des mouvements répétés
pour prendre une analogie si vous
commandez si vous commandez un burger
sur internet que vous vous le faites
livrer chez vous vous attendez à
recevoir un super burger avec un un bon
steak plein de sauce plein de fromage et
au final vous recevez ce à l'expérience
pas du tout vécu dans la réalité 1 avec
une seule rondelles d'oignon est juste
un peu de sauce
donc vous êtes déçu vous êtes déçus les
sensations sont plus fortes les émotions
sont plus forte parce que ça correspond
pas à vos attentes
donc tout ça ça explique pourquoi on
peut pas se trouver soi-même
ouais et surtout à quoi ça sert au final
réellement l'atténuation sensorielle ça
sert à faire la distinction entre soi et
les autres
ce que si on n'avait pas d'atténuation
sensorielle imaginez vous marchez dans
la rue
vous vous touchez sont pas exprès à la
jambe vous avez l'impression qu'il ya
quelqu'un qui vient de vous toucher vous
êtes sur les défensives
l'atténuation sensorielle sensorielle du
coup ça vous sert vraiment à distinguer
vous même des autres ça c'est bien
dommage parce que à cause de cette
atténuation sensorielle on peut pas se
chatouiller soi même et c'est vraiment
dommage parce qu'on aimerait bien s'en
servir par exemple pour se remonter le
moral de temps en temps genre quand vous
ratez votre but c'est que le suivant et
dans 20 minutes
ouais quoi tout le monde sur la balance
après les fêtes de noël par exemple
voilà donc en quand on découvre le
dernier album de julien doré
donc quand même on est on est des gens
très chic on vous a dégoté quelques
manières quand même de se chatouiller
soi même des petits trucs pour hacker
son cerveau et on vous en propose un top
3 alors on commence par le moins fun a
priori c'est d'être schizophrène
alors on n'a pas trouvé des images
d'illustration alors on a mis ça alors
juste être schizophrène c'est pas du
tout un dédoublement de la personnalité
en fait c'est des gens qui ont des
hallucinations visuelles ou auditives
par exemple une petite voix qui leur dit
comment d'un burger en ligne et fais le
toi livres ou alors vous voyez un un
jardin avec lequel vous discutez ou ou
alors vous discutez vous prenez thé avec
la reine d'angleterre
ce genre de choses donc il s'avère que
certains schizophrènes ont une
atténuation sensorielle qui est
défectueuse ce qui fait qu'en fait quand
ils se touchent
ils ont l'impression ils ont beau voir
que la main est relié à leur propre
corps ils ont l'impression que c'est
quelqu'un d'autre qui les touchent nos
qui peuvent vivre ce qu'on appelle une
expérience passive donc qu'ils peuvent
se chatouiller eux même en ayant
l'impression que c'est quelqu'un d'autre
qui les chatouilles bon mais les
schizophrènes en fait sont pas les seuls
à avoir des hallucinations
en fait là vous tous dans la salle vous
avez des hallucinations tous les jours à
un certain moment de la journée
lequel ouais quand vous dormez
quand vous rêvez vous voyez des gens
dans votre tête qui apparemment sont
différents de vous qui peuvent vous
touchez alors pourtant c'est votre
cerveau qui les génère donc que vous
avez une ati une thématisation
sensorielle qui aussi défectueuse un peu
comme celle d'epse schizophrène et si
vous vous réveillez pendant la phase de
sommeil paradoxal la phase de sommeil
pendant laquelle on se rappelle le mieux
rêve et on a les rêves les plus nombreux
si vous vous réveillez pendant cette
phase vous pouvez vous chatouiller au
réveil et à priori ça va marcher parce
qu'à une certaine inertie après le
réveil l'atténuation sensorielle et
diminue vous pourrez essayer cette nuit
par exemple ça et dernière solution on
peut aussi utiliser un robot alors par
exemple oui parce qu'on peut se faire
chatouiller pas autre chose qu'un être
humain
breaking news donc par exemple vous
prenez le petit chien ou tomates que
vous avez offert à votre petit dernier à
noël par exemple vous pouvez
je sais pas vous vous allongez vous vous
vous détendez vous le posez sur votre
vente vous l'allumez est en fait le
mouvement de ses pattes sur votre ventre
ça va vous chatouiller et voilà breaking
news et on a une ultime solution en
vidéo pour se chatouiller soi même qui
nous est confiée par parent youtuber
américain qu'on va vous montrer bientôt
voilà je vais me blay encore ça va bien
saouli son esclave qu'est ce que son
permis d'alcool
moine est né à denain jour mais que
trois attaques au sol c'est l'ultime
solution donc maintenant grâce à nous
vous savez comment vous chatouiller vous
même et ce qui est magique c'est que
toutes ces solutions ne s'excluent pas
les unes les autres donc si jamais vous
trouvez un robot chatouilleur
schizophrène et que vous l'appliquez sur
vous à votre réveil
eh bien vous avez un bingo chatouille
magique voilà donc amis on a oublié
juste de vous presser un petit truc
pardon hein je déborde temps qu'il tant
pis pour les conséquences et de la
chimie et la physique après vol on n'a
pas expliqué l'intérêt des chatouilles
dans la science est en fait l'intérêt
c'est de mieux comprendre ce concept
d'atténuation sensorielle pour mieux
saisir comment on arrive à faire la
distinction entre soi même et les autres
et peut-être pouvoir imaginer un jour
doter les robots par exemple de cette
faculté de conscience de soi en quelque
sorte
voilà merci de votre attention et
n'oubliez pas de vous chatouiller
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
merci à toutes les deux
il est maintenant l'heure d'accueillir
des physiciens et des chimistes sur
scène il est l'heure de débuter la série
qui a un peu démocratisé les geeks
depuis quelques années big bang theory
est de savoir que mais en vrai en vrai à
quoi ça ressemble un physicien un vrai
musique aux rhénans sous vont pouvoir
répondre à cette question
merci vous montrez vidéo de lens
si elle peut pas partir
[Musique]
dirai qui tu es
je ne sais pas
bon ben en fait vous avez prêté ce prix
là on à partir de là les terminaux de
terrain alors qu'il s'était montré hier
un extrait vidéo totalement absurde il y
avait des gens qui sortaient d'un
caisson au fond de l'océan et qui
sortait comme ça et juste avec une
bouteille d'oxygène et itinéraires
remontée juste en agences emballent ya
des compressions et où il puise en
sarthe et en bonne santé
mais bon on s'est dit que ce serait
peut-être mieux d'essayer de faire
quelque chose qui berne scopus de défis
avec avec une série menait des
conseillers scientifiques etc et donc on
penser
nous
je vais donner lundi couple brad wall
alors j'ai senti que ce qui perturbe la
sécu il entend remplir cette pièce
d'ailleurs c'est l'oxygène guitare il
pensa anoxie c'est à dire quand il n'y a
plus suffisamment d'oxygène dans la
pièce et on commence à étouffer s'il
faut que les voir mourir dans le
meilleur des cas puisque nous mais non
ils ont prévu leur coup quand même
donc si tu regardes un petit peu
derrière tu vois qu'il ya une grosse
bonbonne d'hélium au premier plan par
contre ensuite un petit peu derrière tu
vois qu'il ya un doute bonbonnes mac et
auxi en très petit donc il a prévu son
coup il n'a pas rempli la pièce avec de
l'hélium qu il a rempli avec est ce
qu'on appelle de lait yop c'est-à-dire
mélange d'hélium oxygène qui est par
exemple utilisé un projet pour voler une
très grande profondeur
donc pour l'instant ça la marche et ont
ils vont ils ont fait le coup en continu
non
tout soit ok bon il a envie de la pièce
avec un mélange de l'été durée avec six
gènes et donc chef de choeur que je
pense que vous connaissez tous à une
voix inquiètes ce que blizzard a l'air
plus qu'à 6 passes ta pour répondre à ça
il va falloir revenir aux basiques je
pense qu est ce que c'est qu'un sont
alors un son
bah c'est une succession de surpression
et de décompression dans les airs et
donc ces suppressions et des
compressions pour être espacées dans le
temps et c'est de l'espace cet espace
dans le temps le nombre de compression
et de décompression dans une seconde va
nous donner la fréquence que ce son est
donc plus élevé que la fréquence est
élevée
ckrl fréquence tout à fait donc c'est
lorsqu'un objet bible il va pousser vous
retirer de l'air et donc cesser nos de
compression que vous formez ses franges
que vous voyez apparaître les et proches
elles ont aussi périodicité dans
l'espace vous voyez qu'ils sont séparés
par une distance qui est constante et
ses distances on appelle ça la longueur
d'onde ok donc si on voit son plaisir du
bain on accélère notre gifle pour fait
bouger notre ambition c'est le côté un
petit peu plus vite
il fait bouger vers plus vite et donc
qu'on a une fréquence plus élevée à ce
que les élus par contre il ya quelque
chose qui n'a pas changé lorsque tu as
modifié chic c'est la distance entre les
vagues ma longueur d'onde est toujours
là la main parce que on a changé aussi
que votre dos et la vitesse de
propagation si vous voyez
les vagues en l'air d'aller plus en plus
vite d'un côté droit ok donc en fait
c'est ce qui se passe quand on est en
délire les particules qui composent des
hommes sont plus légères elles sont plus
faciles à déplacer et donc non mais
c'est que maintenant
donc ça serait pour ça qu'on aurait une
fois plus aigus pour chaque jeune dans
cette scène donc et c'est pas totalement
le cas ici donc le réseau l'on est long
ce n'est pas ce que vivent la fréquence
bien plus autres sons les plus aigus
mais dans ce cas puisque toute la pièce
remplie avec de l'hélium pourquoi il ya
que le son de shenzhen qui est modifié
et pas la voix du haut parleur par
exemple ton raisonnement devant les
fonctionnaires aussi dans ce cas donc du
coup qu'est ce qui change entre la
chaîne donne et des fans
alors tu couches et non parce que
justement elle dit tout à l'heure
c'était que c'était le piston type g10
acquise et la fréquence est donc ce qui
fait le son pour le téléphone basse et
c'est juste que le parti gauche donc il
fait un peu de piste on reproche elle
donne ses cordes vocales qui dément et
locales qu'elles soient dans l'hélium ou
dans lequel elle vibre à la caisse donc
ça serait pas totalement la voile
sheldon qui vient plus aiguë qui a
quelque chose d'un peu plus louches
derrière donc que fait une corde vocale
et ben ali fait ce qu'on appelle un buzz
c'est à dire un ensemble de sons un peu
indéfini quelque chose comme on voit là
vous essayer à l'extrême
si on fait juste un bruit sont fréquence
défini c'est par exemple vous n'avez pas
de notes qui assure agissez en mélange
de sons qu'on appelle du bruit
maintenant si je fais le même souffle si
fais je le fais dans ce millefeuille on
a une note qui ressort maintenant six
mois je souffle dans ma bouteille d'eau
j'ai une autre note qui semble émerger
donc là c'est la différence entre un
flux six pays africains voilà ce qui
s'est passé là c'est que la bouteille a
sélectionné une fréquence en particulier
mais donc quelle est la différence entre
nous deux bouteilles la mienne l'athlète
est la mienne non
donc ce qui se passe c'est que j'ai créé
des ondes qui se sont propagées dans une
bouteille
et à chaque fois que la rencontre une
perturbation par exemple le fond de la
bouteille ou le boulot lorsqu'elle pas
dans le sens elle va changer de
direction
donc j'ai un fluide ronde qu'il y va il
fait des allers retours des successions
dali retourner et du coup le durée selon
2000 naturel que l'on met à faire des
allers-retours dans la bouteille c'est
ça qui va faire vibrer la bouteille en
elle même et qui va créer notre ondes au
final que nous entendons plutôt qui va
amplifier la fréquence
que j'ai fait une demande si vraiment je
sais une seule en particulière celle que
vous avez entendu tout à l'heure donc en
effet pour la fréquence et le temps que
met on aller retour pour ce faire donc
vous avez deux moyens modifier ça soit
comme on l'a fait en modifiant le trajet
si vous raccourcissent et le trajet long
l'aller-retour en moins de temps donc la
fréquence est le plus rapide
soit vous faites elle est longue plus
rapidement en modifiant la vitesse du
son et donc nalanda plus vite
temps plus court et donc vous avez une
fréquence qui augmente
voilà donc c'est à peu près ce qui se
passe quand on a les lionnes que tom
sheldon pas rebondir du coup si je
donnerai bien parler dans l'hélium
on devrait avoir des fréquences qui sont
les mêmes sur sur sur le spectrum ici
qui sont des compositions de des
fréquences passent et les video
converter est donc pour un somme qui a
été le sont après nation l'hélium voilà
donc ce qu'on s'attendrait si c'était
bien médium c'est que les fréquences
entre soi tout les mêmes
mais j'aimerais qu'il soit plus forte
que les autres et que ce soit les
fréquences plus aiguë que s'amplifier
ici quand il a inhalé des lionnes et que
ce soit des fréquences plus graves
qu'ils soient libérés ils seront obligés
si cantina les gestionnaires donc
conséquences et 4g mais si on regarde la
démo suivante
donc ça va c'est quand il apprit
l'hélium ça c'est quand il a appris des
lieux ici parlent en son et 200 verte
avec seulement normal
ici ils parlent entre 200 et 300 m
avec sa voix aux huiles essentielles
compris les lieux on s'attendrait à ce
que ce soit dans le même endroit
donc soit il à dire que l'hélium et il a
ensuite c'est par les plus aigus soit
ils ont carrément bouger ce prêtre le
spectre informatiquement
donc il a triché mais j'ai quand même eu
question être sûr d'aller montrer que le
débit de la bouteille de gaz n'était pas
suffisant pour remplir la pièce attend
en hélium et serait peut-être aller plus
vite pour la conférence on serait parti
d'un simple
et bien malgré nous allons basculer dans
l'horreur à lesquin à vienne bienvenue
du cinéma les xénomorphes qui est un
parasite qui est il un parasite
remarquable présenté par le tout aussi
remarquable pierre gerner qui le monde
partait pas le bon
alors donc bon ma question j'aime
beaucoup les parasites et la question
c'est est-ce que parmi tous les
parasites
celui qui représentait dans les films
alien le huitième passager à lienz alien
3 prometheus aérienne kobena automne est
un parasite remarquable bombe à la
question mérite d'être posée
la première chose qu'on va se poser
c'est est ce que le cycle de vie de le
budget nos morts va être intéressante
alors pour ça il faut poser la question
qui est des premiers l'oeuf ou le xénon
morse et vous allez voir que en fait en
étudiant attentivement le cycle de vie
qui parasitent qu'est le xénon morpho
s'aperçoit que il ya des complications
et des énigmes qui ne seront pas encore
répondu c'était pas être responsable
c'est pas grave du coup le cycle de vie
du xénon morceaux avec % rennes on va
commencer par sens rennes donc ce convoi
pour le alien le huitième passager tout
commence par un duff qui donne ce qu'on
appelle un fait la gueule
ensuite ça donne un effet stocker qui va
se coller sur un première route un
humain qui va permettre après un temps
d'incubation d'obtenir ce qu'on appelle
un test basten et enfin en zone rouge
donc qui sort et la question c'est
comment on arrive à fermer le site
dans l'allier le huitième passager qu'on
n'a pas de réponse arrive à lienz dans
lesquels ont introduit la réponse une
reine qui prend les eaux
certes mais d'où vient la reine alors
bon on n'a pas de réponse mais on est
dans un film mon sens en moi
personnellement j'envisage tout
simplement que les xénomorphes soit se
transforme en reine soit il attend de
retrouver un autre et xénon mort il
copule ça donne une âme en reste c'est
quand même un tout petit peu compliqué
autre étape qui peut permettre de se
rendre compte que le bal
non ce n'est pas les cerveaux
remarquable c'est cette fameuse étape
dans lequel on voit le racing
ah oui j'ai oublié 10,1 et est-ce que
prometheus nous permet de comprendre
cette situation
mais bien sûr parce que en fait qu'un
ingénieur il ya une sorte de bulle et
inique et puis après il ya un fait bon
en fait non que prometheus n'apporte pas
la réponse
si ce n'est que ça nous apporte la
possibilité d'acheter pour plus de
paracétamol en forme s
intéressons nous plutôt au fait la
gueule les cinq heures dont c'est ce
fameux parasites qui va incubés 1,9 à
l'intérieur d'un autre généralement un
du moins comme vous le voyez ça peut
arriver on quitte à ce que cgi cas pour
obtenir une annulation d'une arme de
chasse basterds qui va sortir au moment
opportun alors constat 1
il ya un seul peuple qui ait conduit qui
donne 1 et no more sortant au stade
larvaire le chase basterds est l'hôte
décède
est-ce que ça c'est gigas les mauves ont
montré un parasite ô combien plus
efficace qu'un faisceau girl voici la
cad parasitaire côté dia que glomerata
une petite guêpe qui a pour habitude de
pondre ses oeufs dans une chenille
elle va pas bon 1 9 mai une douzaine
deux qui vont sortir alors à une
douzaine express une demi douzaine de 2
n 2 qui sortent au stade larvaire et
chose remarquable donc déjà beaucoup
plus d'efficacité
mais l'hôte ne décèdent pas
nécessairement en effet la plupart du
temps loach venir garde dans son corps
une larve parasitaire qui va se ficher à
l'intérieur du cerveau de la cheville
pour en contrôler son comportement
résultat celle ci va devenir un garde du
corps des chenilles qui viennent
d'émerger pour pouvoir réaliser leur
métamorphose tout en ayant un garde du
corps qui va et en enlever tous les
plats tous les éventuels prédateurs et
bien vu
poster c'est une sorte de petite
crevette là qui sortent du ventre 2 de
quelqu'un c'est un peu sensible c'est un
moment où il a pas intérêt à crever
imaginez si les humains se mettaient à
protéger le jazz boston les patates à
tous les gens qui deux approches
ça ça sera un film qui aurait pu arrêter
le plus simple est sûre bref parce que
autre chose
est ce qu'on peut appeler xénomorphes
moi je me suis toujours demandée pour se
donner qu'est ce que c'est que cette
petite maire de ouidah qui reste dans la
bouche dame
alors bon on dit bon ça peut être une
seconde à fort c'est complètement
aberrant va je vous dis à mon avis qui
sait les xénomorphes ces dépouilles des
courses bestiaux qui sont généralement
victimes d'un hyper parasitisme eux
mêmes sont parade faute mais ça à mon
avis c'est d'un autre parasite
le fait est que ça existe dans la nature
le fameux crustacés is opened six motos
a exhibé exidia est un iso beauté qui se
fiche à la place des langues de certains
animaux comme paraissent-ils parasites
oeuvre et parlons ici un vivaneau ici
nemo les accusés n'ont pas été montrés
par dix semaines en tant que tel on voit
ainsi moustoir qui se trouve à
l'intérieur et qui a remplacé la langue
de son hôte et la question qu'on se pose
tous et commence à nyc tout ça je ne
réponds pas
re découvrir dans un livre merveilleux
qui paraîtra aux quatre ans et
maintenant une autre question qui me
turlupine
la question c'est on va on voit quand
même passer un petit moment à regarder
ce qui se passe dans prometheus est la
question c'est donc au pourquoi
prometheus en réécrire une sorte de vie
/ / / / terre pour ensuite balancé des
xénomorphes aisé de se débarrasser d'eux
mêmes je voudrais me répondre à mon avis
les ingénieurs sont de simples aux
agriculteurs planétaire mais un 10-1
ils sont habillés comme des békés deux
là on voit cette étape particulière dans
lequel un ingénieur manger quelque chose
visiblement pour pouvoir se désintégrer
et en semences et la planète pour
ensuite récolté temps qu'un plein de
bonnes choses ça à mon avis c'est tout
simplement une méthode originale de
semis et donc pourquoi il serait casser
la tronche à créer des xénomorphes eh
bien mon avis c'est tout simplement que
c'est un outil de lutte biologique
alors le fait est que ça existe pour
nous on utilise des parasites vous avez
peut-être desjardins dans lequel fallait
pouvoir utiliser des parasites pour vous
débarrasser de nuisibles donc nous ce
serait les humains les usines ce qui
sont débarrassés par les xénomorphes
mais par exemple si vous avez des lignes
vous pouvez utiliser des nématodes
parasites et qui en plus sont très très
pratique puisqu'il tue les limaces ça
mais en plus au moment où la limace se
retrouve dépourvu de toute volonté elle
va s'enterrer sous terre ce qui fait une
quelque chose de beaucoup plus propre
mais vous avez des anti mites également
avec des guépards à ce titre que les
trichogrammes donc à mon avis et ce sera
la conclusion de ma présentation les
ingénieurs c'est tout simplement de bons
derniers
et que ils ont fait 1-1 ce lancement qui
marchent baiia de choses et j'ai donc
hop on leur balance et ex à la force et
c'est réglé
voilà donc tu ne sais d'information si
ça vous intéresse vous pouvez le
découvrir nous agite paparazzi steel
case en plein sinon allez sur l'onglet y
est à bout
[Applaudissements]
merci pierre et enfin contribuer
garantissent en cours sans spoil eva
nous parle à porter une critique sur les
visas de gamme mirror il sa vision d'une
intelligence artificielle
bon on va pas de blagues et aussi les
fans de black bien saison 2 épisode hier
à pétrole pour me fatigue j'ai spolié
quinze minutes de la fin de saison 2 qui
est the bad the way back où il ya le
personnage principal martin elle a un
copain qui s'appellera h&h décède au
début d'épisode ce début les viols et
marta est dépassé on peut imaginer et du
coup ce qu'elle fait c'est en fait
plaisir et qui passe est une amie de
baraki et vince neil martin a incité de
reconstitution de vivre l'identité
digitale d'un défunt qu'est ce que ça
veut dire ça veut dire que en fait ce
que veut faire martha selva juste pour
rire son application de chat préféré que
ce soit facebook whatsapp messenger et
elle va au point de la discussion
qu'elle avait avec avec la shdm le g20
et voir des cons
or je ne sais pas s'il va répondre
puisque moi je la fais un peu robinson a
pu faire son retard mais h va pas
répondre lui-même parce qu'il est mort
mais si la séquence est d'avoir une
intelligence artificielle qui va
analyser toutes les données qui a laissé
sur internet twitter facebook tous
comblés et va essayer d'imaginer comment
h aurait répondu martin alors ça ça peut
paraître technologie très très très très
mondaine mais t'inquiète dans l'obésité
travail sur exactement ça pour que 6 des
pour permettre de retrouver servette qui
travaille sur une intelligence
artificielle avec laquelle on pourrait
aider et vous vous pensez vraiment
naturel et voir plaisante de chatter et
lucas l'ex ready cas j'ai testé
l'application devient mai
la recherche avance très vite et ça
aujourd'hui on n'y est pas du tout mais
j'ai vraiment envie de dire que les
projets sont vraiment spectaculaires
aujourd'hui en octobre 2017
il ya un facebook qui a publié un
article donc t'es juste les énormément
de recherches conditions très difficiles
et des coûts de la filière en 2017 un
article absolument stupéfiante mans
c'est le truc le plus tout était bien
plus stimulant que tout ce que vous avez
pu lire d'autres à mon avis on 26 ans
artificielle le soir ce qu'ils ont fait
et ce boxer ils ont deux gars à lire à
une intelligence artificielle plein de
textes en anglais puis ils l'ont donné à
lire plein de textes en français mais ce
n'est pas des traductions les uns de
l'autre et avait rien à voir si les
textes en anglais texte française il ya
juste lui énormément d'anglais
énormément de français hier à la fin
elle était capable de faire des
traductions de l'anglais au français
sans aucun exemple de traduction c'est
vraiment monstrueux et le plus fou c'est
la manière dont ils sont habillés de ce
qu'elle a fait est là lui plaint d'un
texte en anglais elle a essayé de
construire de sémantique des mots en
anglais
enfin de mathématiques en fait elle
prend des démos et elle essaie de les
transformer en un point dans un espace
de sémantique en fait c'est un point
dans un acteur dont un espace vectoriel
les dimensions 50 ou 100 mais en gros sa
robe ça me correspond juste avoir une
représentation du sens du mot et elle a
fait brailler clubs français lille et
demi mot français elle a trouvé par une
augmentation de lectoure ya des mots de
langue française
ensuite avec deux espaces de son antique
la sémantique en anglais est asthmatique
la sémantique en français elle a trouvé
une façon de coller de superposer ces
deux espaces de ces antiques et ça ça
lui a fait un kanak qui va de desmaures
en anglais à la sémantique en anglais à
la cinématique sémantique en français
comme en français et le plus fou c'est
que ça c'est devenu l'état de l'art elle
a battu toutes les autres indique ans
artificielle dans cette [ __ ]
addiction le mot tam comme si le secteur
est sensible que mot-à-mot a encore du
mal à traduire les phrases les
expressions on salit on est on y est pas
encore et bien sûr aujourd'hui il
interrompt certes il arrive pas un ferry
le sens de tout un paragraphe de tout le
livre sans n'y paraît mais avec avec
mirror saison de f1 cette saison n'était
pas si loin que ça et j'ai vu j'ai
vraiment envie de finir sur sa sur le
fait qu' aujourd'hui voilà je pense que
cet épisode de blagues miroir avec cette
intelligence artificielle dont de
téléphone auquel on n'est pas assez a
dicté sa c'est la manière dont les
intelligences artificielles bon envers
l'autre au quotidien oubliez les robots
que ça c'est trop compliqué à faire
martin est une intelligence artificielle
dans votre téléphone à cadran
vous êtes complètement addict ça ça
risque vraiment d'arriver en fait c'est
déjà arrivé aujourd'hui lundi la sarthe
ils sont partout dans vos téléphones
aujourd'hui l'ille-et-vilaine l'entité
la plus puissante non je pense je pense
qu'on peut vraiment dire que c'est une
intelligence artificielle
je pense que attendent quelque chose
comme le moteur de recherche de google
où ça va intéresser puisque on est entre
youtube et pas mal de joueurs parce que
d'algorithmes de youtube aujourd'hui un
pouvoir vraiment énorme
aujourd'hui l'algorithme de youtube il
est capable de prendre n'importe quel
pouvoir lambda et puis il l'a mètres sur
une pente glissante en allant dans la
ville aux deux maisons plus extrêmes qui
vont aller de yvon l'enfermer dans tout
en haut plutôt humble pour les appels et
voilà il va partir d'une vidéo qui
adhèrent c'est banal et puis petit à
petit à petit on a tous fait
l'expérience commence à regarder youtube
à 9 heures une soirée à trois heures du
matin ce ver nommé naturel et cette
intelligence artificielle et super
puissante elle pourrait faire le bien
pour l acier de suggérer plutôt des
trucs négatifs mais aujourd'hui c'est
pas face aux objectifs de cette
stratégie sa fille si elle nous amène à
nous enfermer dans l'épisode le buzz je
peux finir sur sa faim si ça vous fait
un peu froid dans le dos si ça vous fait
froid dans le dos bienvenue dans black
noir merci
merci à tous devenus s'est terminée en
espérant qu'on d'assises et votre
curiosité
désolé pour la voir déborder en bio et
bon festival si vous vous retrouvez
celle au stand du café des sciences
premier étage au milieu merci à tous
[Applaudissements]